cast IRL will be live in Miami with
Patrick Bet David Donald Trump Jr Matt
Gates and Luke gradkowski join us there
get your tickets by clicking the link in
the description below or by going to
timcast.com
let's jump to this story from the Daily
Mail
Biden 80 is worried he might die before
his son Hunter's legal issues are
resolved and think they will get worse
report claims the first thing I want to
add to this story is
Hunter Biden was about to agree to a
plea over these charges which would
resolve his legal issues like you know
right now okay but to be fair maybe what
Joe is saying is that he knows there is
more to come well at any rate we have
this story from the Washington Post
anxiety ripples through the Democratic
party over Biden uh this I'm just gonna
I'm gonna read it for you quote he is in
a period of period of his life oh wait
wait for dramatic effect I'm going to
start over he is in a period of his life
where passing and death is imminent said
Sharon at Sweda the leader of the
democratic party in Lorraine County in
Ohio
who said she often hears from voters
worried about the president's potential
Frailty we are all in a ticking clock
but you're in when you're at his age or
at Trump's age that clock is ticking a
little faster and that's a concern for
voters quite literally Biden has
expressed concern he's going to die at
some point soon and I mean he's passed
the average life expectancy and a
democrat in Ohio outright said that his
death is imminent and this is based on
his old age
um I I don't know man does does Biden
make it to November does he drop out or
does he drop out dude as I'm watching
and listening to this Destiny video I
mentioned last night where he's becoming
learning all about the barisma stuff
Hunter leaving his laptop at that repair
shop and forgetting about it and then
them seizing the laptop and then
basically leaking the emails and all
this these emails between Hunter Biden
and barisma come out it exposes Joe
Biden's role in basically
Biden said I've never talked to my son
about business I don't know his people
and all that stuff and now not only does
he talk to his son about business there
are recordings of it there's emails
there's texts Hunter says my dad takes
money from me dude you've got you've got
Devin Archer saying that this is what
they were doing they were signing
butinski was saying that this is it this
is the Biden business it all came out
man and they were not expecting that I
think Biden it's the it is the stress is
crushing his brain like I remember
um uh what's his name Reagan like became
had Alzheimer's all the stuff and they
were like was he hiding something were
there secrets that he didn't want to
tell about something they were like I
don't remember they were like what do
you remember what that was there was
something I asked him if he could that
if he did something and he was like I
can't remember because of Alzheimer's
and that was convenient it was hitting
his last couple years as president
there's no question about that but Joe's
already there Joe's been there since he
won the presidency I'm sure they're in
the debates they just jacked him up with
B12 just to get himself thinking I could
not believe when I saw him actually come
out like talking yeah the amount of like
this guy the amount of corruption that I
don't know if there's Obama that put
Biden as Point man in Ukraine uh and
then Biden decided I'm gonna bribe the
guy you oh really you're gonna make do
some class a felony to bribe this
corrupt uh that's on tape and then he
admits to that he admits to doing the
bribe like what a quid pro quo does
anybody really believe he has no idea
about his son's business dealings I mean
the Ridiculousness of that alone but
they've got they've got there's a list
of all these lies he said you know
apparently he fought in World War one as
well but I mean I don't know it's just
weird what they he gets away with I know
Joe Biden claimed and you're not going
to believe this lie that he's been
serving the United States government for
800 years
yeah yeah he was joking but the thing
they do is Trump will say something
that's obviously not true or it's
hyperbolic or a joke and they'll say it
was a lie instead of course that's the
that's that's the game but the question
here is if Democrats are worried about
the life of Joe Biden and Joe Biden is
worried about the life of Joe Biden
should we as the American people be
concerned about the health of our
president and whether or not he will
remain our president over the short
future because everyone wants Kamala to
take over because remember when she was
running against the other 12 people
during the Democrat primary she was the
first to booted off so 98 of Democrats
didn't want it for president but it's
crazy that they chose her it's it's you
know you know what I think hey they they
put a woman in the Supreme Court that
can't Define what a woman is that's
crazy that's perfect there is there one
theory is that they were going to run
they wanted to run literally anyone the
the article from I think was the
Atlantic is stay alive Joe Biden all we
need is your corporeal form and it's
because people wanted to vote against
Donald Trump so I'm wondering if their
attitudes were like let's pick pick the
worst candidates imaginable and then
make the election only about Donald
Trump but so it was an anti-election but
the barisma stuff I don't think they
knew I think Hunter went in there and
took that job on the board without Joe
knowing because Hunter's such a piece of
trash I don't know he went over there
with Devon Archer and they so then the
president of Ukraine they were like
let's do a deal and they're like not
interested go to Poland and do a deal
with the president of Poland so they go
there president Poland's like Devin you
should go back to Ukraine join the join
the board of barisma Devin's like that's
a good idea so they go back Hunter and
Devin go back to Ukraine
they go to barisma they go to uh
zlachevsky and they're like hey let's I
want to join the board and he's like
interesting idea actually we want you on
the board Hunter some guy that he said
is stupider than his dogs lachesky said
that Hunter is stupider than his dog but
he put him on the board of his oil
company to use him for access to his dad
to read Biden Inc Politico magazine
2019. Biden knew what Hunter was doing
he knew about the board I wonder if he
knew about everything that Hunter was
doing you you read read the story Biden
ink it talks about 2011 with the Biden
family Fortune's tracking alongside Joe
Biden's career the the the 10 of the big
guy stuff goes well well way earlier
than just 2014 in bursma yeah but I
wonder if Hunters stupidly took this job
that makes no sense it makes an idiot it
no it makes no sense that Joe Biden is
enriching his family and then all of a
sudden one day even though he's the
point guy on Ukraine his son randomly
just goes there he was supposed to be
Devin Devin was supposed to be the board
guy and then they they asked to do it
Hunter's like yeah definitely yeah and
and they're like what the hell now the
vice president's son's on the board
that's not what we intended that's an
excuse to protect the body I'm just
trying to think about it it could just
be the Joe orchestrated it I don't know
but so either way Hunter is an idiot and
he did a stupid thing by joining that
board when when Joe Biden is put in
charge of these key projects and then
his family starts getting enriched off
of the off of ancillary contracts
related to these projects or government
issues I don't think it's a coincidence
to say that the bidens were doing this
for a long period of time and the one
time it was an accident was barisma
makes no sense I wouldn't call it an
accident I just don't know okay the
Occam's razor suggests that if the
bidens are peddling influence well
before 2014 the barisma deal was part of
that influence peddling that's it Biden
was the point guy on Ukraine he said he
was in the CFR meeting he says I get the
tough assignment so they send me to
Ukraine all of a sudden Hunter Biden's
on the board yeah 10 for the big guy he
knows look at this Biden Inc Politico
magazine talks about out how his brother
gets lucrative contracts as soon as Joe
Biden's put in charge of Iraq so then he
gets put in charge of Ukraine Hunter
Biden appears on the board of this
Energy company surprise surprise Devon
Archer testifies that when the
prosecutor is investigating Hunter Biden
calls DC asking for help Biden then
flies out within the immediate I think
it was a few days two weeks later two
weeks he makes an email two days later
and then like two weeks after that he
flies out there two weeks after that he
flies out and says fire this prosecutor
that's not a coincidence Biden didn't do
this on accident Hunter wasn't
accidentally there they know exactly
what they're I think it's November 22nd
of 2015 is when Biden flew out there I
thought it was February I don't want to
get the dates wrong here yeah but I'll
reference Destiny's video again at the
end of the at the end of the video all
the data is in it so they're not
Hunter's legal issues they're Biden's
legal issues they're Joe's legal issues
I mean it's both of them man if if they
did that they colluded together to sell
us out to Ukrainian oil a corrupt
Ukrainian oil company and set us up for
World War III like those guys are
oh I'll let the public and the courts
decide no honest person who knows the
story and the facts
would tell you that Joe Biden is
innocent because there is no
circumstance I mean we're talking like
the the likelihood that all of these
things happen as Joe Biden describes
them despite all of his lies so far on
it it's just by by 10 lottery tickets
buy buy a lottery ticket for every
different major Lottery game and win all
of them good luck I got the feeling that
uh Obama was like Joe you're taking
Ukraine you're the point man and Joe's
like I'm gonna go fight those Soviets
I'm going out there I'm gonna stop I'm
gonna protect us from the Soviets and
this whole thing's been like yo bro the
Communists are in our country Joe
they're not over there the Communists
are gone from stop defending Joe Biden
no well I'm trying to understand Joe
Biden I can very easily the the idea
that Joe Biden was like I'm gonna go to
Ukraine to do some good to help America
isn't it an insane view to have based on
all the facts that we already have yeah
look at this story I mean political
reports this in 2019 over as decades in
office middle class Joe's family
fortunes have closely tracked his
political career they had this really
amazing video breaking it all down where
they actually show if it even loads
paradigmund that you they actually let
me see if I can jump to uh one of these
images it shows a timeline and this is
this is Politico Politico is not a
right-wing publication
you should you guys should watch this
actually yeah this works I can uh it's
not let me scroll
they talk about let me see if I can pull
up uh if talk about Iraq during Obama
year several months after James joined a
construction firm as executive The Firm
received a contract worth more than a
billion dollars to build houses in Iraq
while Joe oversaw the us-led occupation
of that country along the way James
partnered with his nephew Hunter the
younger of Joe's two sons a graduate of
Georgetown yeah blah blah blah struggled
with substance abuse et cetera et cetera
et cetera they've been documenting this
this has long been documented we know
this is the case the idea that well
before Ukraine we're talking Iraq we're
talking 20 2011.
the idea that his brother is getting
these lucrative contracts and that Joe
is overseeing the government operations
and his brothers now getting getting the
corporate capitalist contracts that when
it came to Ukraine it's the one time Joe
Biden was like I'm gonna go do good to
fight Soviets no he was like what's my
assignment Obama uh Barack and Brock's
like take care of you crying and he goes
all right hey hey uh Devin and Hunter
how can we make money off this I'm in
charge now on the bus
there you go that's the Biden family I
believe that they did do that uh whether
Joe instigated it or Hunter instigated I
don't know but I think you know they say
the evil people think they're doing good
I I think that he's justifying like he's
actually fighting the Communists no way
dude protecting us from the Soviets
you're talking about the distinction
between you're talking about the
distinction between lawful good and I'm
sorry lawful evil and catech evil Joe
Biden is chaotic evil he does or maybe
maybe neutral evil or or actually no
that's completely wrong you've got the
the people who uh lawful man how do you
break this down lawful good could be
evil following the law to be good or I
guess you'd call that lawful zealous
paladins man they're dangerous right
they have to do good no matter what Joe
Biden's the guy who's like I'm doing
good for my family nothing else matters
so you can argue that he thinks he's
doing good by enriching his family
because that's all this world is there
was I talked about this earlier today
when I was doing a video on uh uh it was
the video on Russell Brand you uh you
have these videos there's a video that
went viral the hyenas he eating like a
wildebeest or something alive they're
disembowling it as it struggles to get
up and they said the the idea that the
world is fair is incorrect In fact it is
the most uh vicious of aggressors that
succeed and are rewarded for their
actions Joe Biden probably has the
predator mindset yeah he does and so his
attitude is you don't matter
all that matters is that he gets power
from whatever whatever he can and if you
talk to him he'd be like geopolitics is
a dirty game like that's how he'd
justify it well all I can say is this is
very disappointing next thing you'll
tell me Nancy Pelosi has she can
manipulate the stock market no I don't
think she has any ability to uh oh yes
she does insider trading if you have
that like Nancy Pelosi's stock track
stock tracker that exists where it's
like yeah you want to get rich I was
being sarcastic by the way
if you're looking for a financial
advisor I'd recommend reaching out to
the financial advisors of members of
Congress yes figure out which company
Nancy Pelosi is using to handle her
deals and just say hey look whatever
Nancy does that's what I'm doing I think
oh that's all Inconvenient Truth all you
do when Al Gore came out you should
invested in everything he put his money
into with this whole climate change
things he made a lot of money yeah fauci
made a couple million bucks I think I'll
give you a couple million couple million
on top of the book deal yeah this I
think that Biden's brain has been
destroyed by this Hunter's revealment by
the laptop getting revealed because it
basically implicates the entire Biden
family like Hunter and Joe with all this
criminal corruption working with uh
barisma it's discuss I mean and I think
that his brain is so did he get in the
Georgetown on his grades or was it
because of his name of uh uh Hunter yeah
I don't know they said he has a law
degree I have no idea what the hell's
going on thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday 8 pm
and become a member over at timcast.com
for uncensored members only shows
exclusive thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all next time